you
nine people are still missing this
morning after the deadly boat fire and
explosion off the coast of Southern
California at least 25 people were
killed after the fire broke out on a
charter boat early yesterday morning
today we're hearing from a couple who
rescued the five survivors Meg Oliver's
in Santa Barbara Harbor where the boat
launched from a small memorial there is
drawing with flowers candles and even a
pair of flippers meg how does a couple
describe what they saw and must have
been terrifying
Maria Elena good morning they described
pure hor the boat used to dog right
behind me next to its sister ship we
talked to the couple Bob and Shirley
Hansen who anchored their boat for the
night without knowing what they would
stumble on a fire broke out on another
boat several hundred feet away they
saved five men who were soaked and
shivering from the water or they looked
helplessly at the flames and then I
heard help frantic knocks woke up Bob
and Shirley Hansen in the middle of the
night on their fishing boat five people
from a boat nearby sought help after
escaping a fire soon as I came out I saw
the man with the broken leg lying in the
bottom of the dinghy in water my wife
here assisted the guys they opened the
door here so that they could slide there
the fellow with the broken leg in and we
had him right here you got him some
pillows and a blanket and some towels
they said some of the crew members tried
to go back and rescue the others but
found no one at first it's you know like
you feel helpless but now you know it's
settling in and you know it's one of
those things you just can't unsee the
hansen say their own daughter has gone
diving on that same boat before and have
a family friend who is a dive master who
did not make it out rescue operations
are still ongoing as family members of
the nine people still unaccounted for
wait for answers Anthony all right thank
you med fortunate for the crew the
Hansen's were there